okay so let's talk about some of the
elements of
um what's going on with the Dynamics
here because a lot of people will come
up with the morality of it all I want to
set that aside and just deal with
The evolutionary psychology elements of
um going outside of your relationship
because men and women do it for
different reasons I don't know if you
caught any of the stuff that I've talked
about in that area before are you
familiar with why men go outside and why
women go outside
why women go outside yeah well yes yes I
I understand outside of the relationship
so just recap for the people watching
like
the the problem that she's got is she's
got a security issue with the whole
thing like she wants to know that he's
not going to remove his attention his
resources his love his protection his
provisioning to her and the soon-to-be
child that comes you know with that like
does that sound about accurate to you
that's very accurate yeah so that's what
that's what women are concerned about so
when a guy cheats she doesn't really
care that much it's generally she's
going to ask questions like well did you
love her did you take her to the
restaurant that we go to are you going
on vacation with her is she now your
girlfriend like the last thing I'm
assuming that you want from what I've
you know learned with all the reading
that I've done is that the last thing
you want is a woman to show up at your
front door knocking on it and she's
pregnant with his child yeah yeah that
was literally the worst thing I could
ever think of right but as far as him
going outside and having some uh safe
fun
um you've set some rules and your rules
are based on the use of Instagram so no
emojis the use of Disappearing messages
no WhatsApp calls so really just like a
one night stand like a quick encounter
yeah
okay and why are you okay with that
it seems disconnected uh I guess like my
fear of him creating any new connection
emotionally to any other woman is
removed when it is a one-night stand but
we did actually talk a bit more in depth
about what comes with one-night stands
and the the condom wrapper that I found
he said it was from a one-night stand it
was from um a girl visiting the island
and he said it's a lot more public going
that route if you're if he's out with
his friends out in a club
um that route has its own challenges too
and it can be a lot more public more
people may see
um him actually making a move in that
case so he asked me is that something
I've even thought about
versus a quiet local girl who
yeah
would you be okay if he had a steady
side girlfriend
no
so it's so it's just got to be like a a
visitor a traveler a one night thing and
that's it
uh
well you said
it's 30 second girlfriend the good
girlfriend I don't like that but I it
needs to be more disconnected than that
for me even more yeah one of the things
I've I've heard in conversations quite
often in fact I had a conversation with
a guy about this the other day and he
was telling me you know his girl was
okay with it but she would prefer if you
use prostitutes
um you know just because there's as
little connection as possible right
um so back to the point of of what men
are seeking and what women are seeking
so women want the security they want the
provisioning they want the love like
it's been a thing for thousands of years
I mean you know today we live in a
modern society where women don't really
need the protection of a man you know
you hear the toxic feminists say things
like I need a man like a woman needs a
bicycle or like a fish needs a bicycle
sort of thing and that's fine but you
know for thousands of years if if a
woman became pregnant and she didn't
have the protection the provisioning and
the love of the guy that fathered the
child she was at very real risk of
um not being able to provide for
um and you know like anything critical
beyond that obviously so it's ingrained
within men and women right so
he's actually going about it a fairly
reasonable way one of the things that um
I read and I've heard you say you know
when it comes to him going outside of
the whole relationship and the trust
thing is you want to be careful with
that from what I understand you don't
want to have too much in a way of rules
for him like don't don't do this don't
do that don't do this like the more
rules you have the more difficult
um it it becomes and it and it becomes
an area that you're going to police
right like it should be something's
comfortable yeah like it should be
something simple like look uh don't take
her out anywhere where I would be
embarrassed where family and friends
would see us
um no overnights no vacations uh ideally
tourists only that you know that come
and go yeah
keeping it simple if you're going to do
it is going to be a better way to do it
like one of the things that I was
concerned about when I read the email
which is why I offered to bring you on
it's like you almost seem like you're at
the point where
you had difficulty like getting the
trust back and the problem is that
you're pregnant right like you've got a
kid coming and a child needs
his or her father
and I think one of the worst things that
women can do is leave
leave a father that absolutely loves and
adores you just because he steps out
right yeah
um
like you do that and you think that
you're going to replace him with
somebody else that's not a good scene
because the most risky thing to a small
child especially if it's a girl is a
non-blood related
um man or even you know step sibling if
he's got a son in tow or something like
that that could expose your kid to a lot
of risk like nobody's gonna love that
kid any more than what he will nobody's
going to provide protect and you know
preside over the family and the child
any better than what he will so you're
doing the right thing by keeping them
around again setting aside the morality
because everybody has their own views
and opinions the thing is as human
beings aren't particularly good at
monogamy we kind of suck at it you know
for being honest I talk about it in a
chapter or two of my book and I've
talked about it in many different videos
but it's just the reality of the way the
world Works
um and it's very different when men and
women do it like when women do it she's
she's usually done like women don't
want to generally step out on a
relationship if she sees him as her
hypergamous best option she wakes up 100
you know look you look at your husband
and you're in love with him and you see
him as the best that you can do and
you're happy with your life and he takes
care of things and the bills were paid
and the house is looked after and he's
competent and he's interesting he's
influential like if you have all of
those things leaving a guy is about the
stupidest thing that you can do thinking
that you can replace him and doing
better right
exactly and I think uh it's very
important for women to choose men who
who have had a lot of experience with
women
I know that way I know that when it
comes to him dealing with women that
he's not gonna be so attached
um
emotionally
so I know like I said in the email that
he's going to be able to be with these
girls and
just leave it
like
even when I read the the Instagram
message my heart sank because he said
something to them that was like oh a
little like you know soft and I was like
why did you say that to her what did he
what did he say that uh triggered you I
think he sent like um a gift
that was like a an Hibiscus flower and
he said
um
so this girl is like a naturey girl what
I gathered and he said um
your soul this is your your what your
soul looks like or something like that
right and I was really upset with that
mainly and I was like that's interesting
how why did you uh
what what does that even mean why are
you sending her that and he he said the
it's [ __ ] do not look into that this
is what these girls want to hear
yeah because it's essentially I was like
no Emojis
yeah so it's so it's essentially him you
know running game but by playing the
game Yeah Yeah by playing the game but I
mean like what you're saying is you
can't use the tools of the game or you
can't use all the tools of the game so
I'm fine with you talking to them but
you can't use emojis or gifs to yeah
accomplish what I'm but I'm blessing you
to accomplish simply because you don't
want that to turn into romance right and
do you think that's reasonable
look the fewer the rules that you issue
in scenarios like this the better off
you're going to be right and what I
found from my experience dealing with a
lot of the guys and gals that I've
coached in this area is that the biggest
thing is she doesn't want to be
embarrassed
she doesn't want some random woman
knocking on your front door saying
surprise I have your husband's baby in
my belly those seem to be the two and
she doesn't want any kind of diseases so
those seem to be the two to three main
areas and if you limit yourself to just
that and if you live in a I mean you've
already revealed that you live on an
island so I mean if you live on an
island then you can get to the point
where it's like fine just deal with
tourists I want them to come and go like
you know the the wins when they flow in
different directions in the morning and
that'll keep things simple for you and
it gives him the opportunity to still be
a father to scratch a niche when he
needs it and you give him the space to
do that but he's still able to provide
and like you're still a family right you
still love each other you're still
intimate together yeah right
so it sounds like you've got it all
sorted out
yeah I think we do I think since we had
that conversation and
like you said earlier he just put my
mind at ease he he settled me down and
just said
well you just asked me to trust him and
I realized you know what it's going to
be so much easier if I do this than to
try and police what he's doing he he
knows now what I don't want him to do he
can choose to follow that if he wishes
the Emojis and whatnot but if he doesn't
then
I still trust him that he'll he'll do
the right thing yeah and
um you know surprise surprise this is
not a common type of marriage this is
not a common type of relationship but if
you're going to allow him some wiggle
room to exercise his options you're
going about it the right way hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out